[Music]  why is one of the most affluent stars in  the world right now throwing eggs at his  neighbor's house because he's a idiot  yeah I just like to write down your  answers a job I feel like he's got all  those guys around he's just running out  of things to do I know so rich and so  successful and be like what do you want  to do he like let's shave a dog what do  you want to do we've done everything  else it's got all these cars right so I  don't I don't I probably just bored him  yeah I hope I get to that point of my  career I passed that point in my career  that was me in 2002 Andy and I just  sitting around my huge place in  Calabasas shaven dogs Wow and you got  men fooling eggs at the shaved dogs yeah  I feel like he's got to do some toilet  papering of a tree of some sort yeah  yeah leave the dog poop on fire at a  prayer yeah it's weird how he's going  back to pranks from 1950